Victor time wolf let's give it to Victor
what's up Vic hey rage how are you good
man how's it going
so far so good could you remind me about
the getaway girls getaway and all of
that stuff like uh was a procedure for
that sorry the getaway girls
well not get away girls but like for
example uh my date wants to go out it
was a with her friends to out in the
cottage okay and and she invited me over
but due to my work like I'm not in a
city all the time so I'm kind of
contemplating allowed her to go or not
got it okay so you're asking if it's
okay if she goes to a cottage with her
girlfriends or yeah yeah and her
boyfriend's I guess like her
boyfriends as a girlfriend's boyfriends
okay so look
if it's if it's her and her girlfriends
going to a cottage for a weekend have
fun let me know that you got there safe
you know I'll see you when you get back
it's no sweat it's no worries but if
it's hey uh you know my girlfriend's
having some friends over and we're gonna
go to her Cottage
um I know you're working this weekend so
I'll see you when I get back your next
question is who's going to be there
well it's just my second question yeah
well it's you know it's just going to be
my girlfriends and their boyfriends and
stuff like that and it's like okay now
we're getting into there's other dudes
there are there going to be other dudes
that are bringing their friends there
right because that's that's something
that I would want to know like my chick
knows that that is unacceptable she
won't even ask that question
right so like look
guys bring this up often it's like well
you know you're just insecure or you're
too controlling it's like no
um I drive a nice car I'm not gonna park
my car in a shitty neighborhood and hope
that it'll be okay in the morning I know
the chances of it something happening to
a nice car in a shitty neighborhood are
higher than having the car in my garage
overnight at my house with the door
closed so it's just look if if I care
about something like my car I'm going to
take care of it I'm going to make sure
that I don't expose it to risk I'm going
to make sure that I don't put it in a
situation where
another dude is gonna bang it let's say
right so Cottages weekends drinking
drugs you know weeds stuff like that
campfires outside everybody has a good
time
you know stuff happens
how do I know I grew up in Canada
there's a lot of cottage action right
stuff happens so it's a question that
you have to ask and clarify and if you
see that there's going to be risk
exposure to your relationship and that
matters to you then you have to put your
foot down and say look
um I just can't take a woman seriously
if she's going to be hanging out with
other guys when I'm not around
if if it's an early dating you know
scenario where you've only been seeing
her for a few months but she's like I
dig your Vibe I want to claim you I
don't want to share you blah blah blah
and then the next brush she goes next
week and I'm going to my girlfriend's
Cottage there's a few people coming over
they're bringing their boyfriends and
there's going to be a bunch of people
there but you can't come or you're not
invited or you're busy or whatever it's
like I don't date women that you know
hang out with other dudes like that's
that's all you have to say and you leave
the baller she is all aware about it
because she's your girlfriend right so
it's like look if there's going to be
other dudes a girlfriend yeah but if
there's going to be other dudes there
then you know it's it's something that
you have to contend with you know do you
want to let it happen do you want to
park your car in a shitty neighborhood
that's up to you
okay thank you you're welcome brother
see you later I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out